hallo mein name ist luca herzlich
willkommen heute zu einem neuen video
seht ihr schon im titel eingeblendet ich
wollte heute einfach mal images nach
steiners gerade mit dem thema und es
sind draußen halt irgendwie bei uns
gerade 35 grad deswegen habe ich mir
gedacht eigentlich wollte gar kein video
hochzuladen und ich lag dann auf jeden
fall im garten und hab mir dann einfach
mal das ios 10 ab darunter gesehen da
gibt es neue images deswegen dachte ich
mir jetzt von den alten demo die sowieso
ein bisschen zu verabschieden versuche
ich mal 15 stück irgendwie nach
zustellung zur info das video hier wird
wahrscheinlich nicht lang und nicht
interessant und e komplett scheiße weil
es halt main kanal habe ich dachte
vielleicht ist es wirklich einfach
meinen motiven aufzustellen lernst du
das erste match ist dieser böse böse
gucken der hier das muss irgendwie so
machen und so jetzt haben wir diese
tänzerin
das ist schon ein bisschen schwieriger
weil ich halt ich ok ich muss ganz
körper drauf sein wie hat das rechte
bein vorne und die rechte an hinten das
heißt gegen wieso hier in schnelle
freunde haben aber irgendwie so weiter
vorn ich habe natürlich jetzt auch ein
kleidern aber ich doch so das nächste
release ist hier mit der zunge
rausgestreckt also ein ganz breites
gesicht machen die zunge raus
der verdutzte smiley mache ich selber
wirklich sehr häufig als locker mal 200
dritter meisten genutzt dass miley
irgendwie deswegen händen dran am und
google höhere der komplett wütendes
miley ich kann jetzt nicht irgendwie da
ging's raus machen irgendwie dieses
diese wolken die war ihm auskommen habe
ich ganz normal mit mit der not only
versuchen
marco de luca maske toll wie soll ich
denn im mund masken kriegen ja höchst
ist noch im sommer wenn da was ich mir
in europa und kann jetzt hinten
fischerinnen und ich glaube ich muss mir
sogar nötig brauchen zu machen das heißt
java server so toll das ist gut
es ist so ein up der erkennt immer der
smiley kissen da hinten als gesicht und
ich muss immer wieder bei mir drauf
klicken sie dass er mich selbst erkennt
ihre diese scheiße aus dem navi nutzer
für das rechte auge muss zu dass winke
komplett auf und die zunge raus jetzt
beide augen komplett auf rote banken
habe ich nicht aber die augenbrauen
hochziehen und mund zu zähne fletschen
und irgendwie augen ganz klein also das
sind jetzt keine richtigen augen
abgebildet das heißt einfach das mädchen
mit der hand nutze ich auch sehr häufig
also die hand muss auf jeden fall so und
darlehen so auf nasen höhe
wie macht sie das hans asen höhe mund
auf es gilt der kurs meinung mit augen
zu also irgendwie so miley ich habe
jetzt nicht so eine typische schwarze
railway nicht nur diese das ist glaube
ich die klappe erreger tatsächlich hat
der verein ist einfach breiten grinsen
der ich wenigstens mal die also er guckt
glaube ich nach liegt das ist für mich
übrigens sehr komisch das ganze macht zu
stellen dass der spiegelverkehrt ist und
ich muss immer umdenken bei diesen
smileys nach links gucken und so ein
bisschen
ich weiß ich habe den mund aufgemacht
verließen aber du kannst halt den mund
nicht so machen wie er beides welt die
so obwohl man das relativ gut
der abriss miley mit den händen von und
geforderte ja ich bin kein affe so
inzwischen nutze ich quasi nie aber ich
versuche ihm nachzustellen so ein
bisschen grinsen und dann einfach froh
so das was ihr von dem video meine damen
und herren ich weiß es nicht so kreativ
also ich habe mich einfach gedacht okay
bevor heute geht gar kein video kommt
stelle ich mich zumindest und 20 minuten
hier rein und versuchen partys
nachzustellen
vielleicht findet ihr es ja witzig wenn
ihr das so empfunden haben dass auf
jeden fall mike da schreibt man etwas
nettes in die kommentare nicht
verrechnete kommentare will sondern
einfach weil man überall auf youtube nur
noch hague sieht ich meine mich juckt es
nicht es machen schon genug leute videos
zu wirklich dummer kritik aber hey
freunde wenn ihr helfen wollt dann geht
vielleicht woanders hin oder selber
konnte den ihr dann feiert oder so ich
finde das ist ein bescheuertes hobby
negative kommentare mit der negativen
message irgendwie mit hate verpackt ins
internet unter videos zu schreiben von
leuten die das machen worauf sie bock
haben und was habt ihr für menschen ihr
seht ihr in smiley eingeblendet wenn ihr
darauf wie könnte meinen kanal
abonnieren werde doch kein abonnent sein
ist auf jeden fall empfehlen zeitweilig
vielleicht nochmal und schwachsinn
hochladen und hier sieht es auch schon
eingeleitet da habe ich instagram bilder
nachgestellt auf jeden fall mal
ausschenken war auch und total
bescheuertes video also macht worauf er
bock hab aber lasst euch nicht von
irgendwelchen leuten die irgendwas
dagegen sagen den spaß verderben